new satellite images suggest russia has
further bolstered its military presence
near ukraine
the west is now responding in kind with
an american carrier strike group in the
region and thousands of u.s troops on
route to russia's doorstep it's
important that we send a strong signal
to mr putin and frankly to the world
that nato matters to the united states
it
matters to our allies the u.s will
redeploy 1 000 troops currently
stationed in germany to romania another
two thousand troops will be dispatched
from the us most to poland and some to
germany none will be placed directly in
ukraine it's all meant to send a message
that the west isn't backing down
problem is neither is russia russia's
security concerns are mostly bluff and
bluster but russia's desire to protect
and preserve a sphere of influence isn't
integral to its self-image as a country
and to also putin's uh geopolitical
legacy
a spanish newspaper obtained the written
responses to vladimir putin's security
demands in them the u.s and nato offered
to negotiate new disarmament treaties if
russia de-escalates in the region
there are no concessions on putin's
insistence that nato claw back from
eastern europe and bar new member states
like ukraine a failure of the west
in ukraine
will send a message across the globe
that the west is incapable of defending
its core principles and thus incapable
of defending itself
during a wednesday phone call british
prime minister boris johnson warned
putin that an invasion would be a tragic
miscalculation
the next move is russia's to make the
biden administration insists the new
troop deployment is consistent with what
the u.s has already told russia it's
about combat readiness and about
reassuring nervous nato allies who've
seemed uncertain about confronting the
russian threat
donna
jackson proskow in washington thanks